I'm gonna start with a prologue so I'm
not gonna jump into my prepared talk I
want to just read this prologue which I
think is phenomenal stuff this is Adrian
Bernoulli and this is jeremy bentham
sort of having a conversation over the
centuries jeremy bentham wrote in 1791
this paper of political tactics Adrian
berm you'll commented on it 2010 for a
conference in France so this is all
Adrian's writing Bentham notices that
successive votes by the same body under
different transparency regimes from
catching a breath sometimes teach
strikingly different outcomes sometimes
reach slightly different outcomes here's
some otter examples from a range of
institutions and groups maybe I should
read on yeah in the Italian parliament
of the 1970s and 1980s the practice was
that bills designated as issues of
confidence by the government would be
voted upon first by open ballot and then
by secret belt this is a rare species in
the world right so you could actually do
two types of votes open and then secret
or secret and then open so his paper he
goes through and tries to find all and
he's got more examples that we want him
to show here this phenomenal stuff the
results frequently differed I will say
always every example that I've seen in
1986 batino crack sees government won
the open vote of confidence by margin
greater than a hundred about 600 votes
pretty big margin only to be defeated by
the secret ballot craxi was forced to
resign in Alaska judicial council was
charged with a merit-based appointment
of judges until 1967 the council used a
secret ballot but switch to an open
ballot after an episode where everyone
was bragging about how much they're for
a particular candidate and then when the
vote happened he'd lost okay so I'm
gonna leave you with those ideas we're
going to come back to these two
characters throughout this talk they're
amazing characters I think they are who
we are okay they're struggling with some
of the same issues that we struggle with
so my talks called the ghost bill in the
cardboard box ghost bill because 1972 a
House of Representatives commenting on a
particular bill was amazed that no one
wants to talk about it
can't get press about it Boston Globe
has no articles about this bill
the ghost bill okay so 1972 he's talking
about a bill from 1970 and a cardboard
box a story about the 24 words that
changed the world I originally called it
something happened in the 70s partly
because I'm a historical buffoon I don't
know my history very well I was living
in Africa as she mentioned and I was
disturbed about climate change I left
when I started to see a lot of problems
there with respect to climate change
fruits that were going off at the wrong
time et cetera so I came back and I was
like all right I've got to start to
understand policy I started to read
everything I could and you're gonna see
the graphs I was seeing just in a month
of reading okay so this is Paul Krugman
his graph was talking about this amazing
rise in debt that looks a lot like the
amazing rise in debt leading up to the
first Gilded Age okay
Stiglitz mentions the 70s and there
everyone's talking about this great time
between the 30s and the 70s 50s and the
70s and he's talking about how policy
made everything better and then it
disintegrated okay and I just want to
make it clear this is economic stuff
we're talking about okay so today we're
talking a lot about economics Piketty is
a rock star this year he he basically
launched the graph that everybody uses
Robert Reich uses his graph and you can
see what's happening this is inequality
dropping from the first Gilded Age down
to a low in 1976 but kind of wrote real
low in the early 70s and then shoots up
like a rocket ship
this doesn't look like a rocket ship to
you but it's a rocket ship okay it's
going up fast he talks about the same
thing that's the same thing we're gonna
float through these because we're short
on time the left talks about this
Lawrence Lessig talks about how campaign
finance the thing he focuses about takes
off in 74 I think that has to do with an
election cycle so in 74 campaign finance
for a congressman was around what I
don't know 77 million by 1982 the number
was 343 million by 2010 1.8 billion
exponential rise okay Elizabeth Warren
talks about the opposite effect
ages for males are flat from what well
of course from 1970 I just kept seeing
it right and she too talks about what
singlets is talking about how bankruptcy
laws and everything started to
disintegrate beginning in the 70s she
says very often before 1970 there were
no back big banks collapsing why well
it's interesting
I keep hearing this date here's the
right Paul Ryan here's Ron Paul he's
talking about increasing regulations
he's talking about increasing
expenditures I'm highlighting 1970 and
make it easy executive pay and the 1% we
all know this the church going into
government lobbying what's their deal
but in 1970 it turns ok incarcerated
Americans looks maybe more like the 80s
but it's certainly something's happening
right this is my favorite this is
polarization this is partisanship ok so
again we look back towards the Gilded
Age we look back to the early century
and we see partisans been dropping
steadily ok and then it doesn't turn
like a slow curve like switching from
bell-bottoms to straight legs it turns
on a die ok and it shoots up like a
rocket ship I've seen this before
here's just so you know these are some
of these are more scholarly this is the
guy at a Princeton McCarty and barber
that's their graphs a graph basically
the same data ok presidential and
ability to reel in spending we're
familiar with that it's interesting who
it is disappearance of unions seventy
they drop like a rocket ship okay and
unions are important separation of
powers we miss them even though they
were bullies growth and complexity all
right I really want you to think about
this how many pages is the US tax code
right you all just did your taxes it's
gotten insane and the wording in
particular has gotten insane it's harder
and harder to read it okay this also
takes off and we see more data about
that growth and complexity of bills the
number of pages of bills the wording of
bills all of that has grown
exponentially in 2000 let's see well at
some point in the past in the 40s there
were about 2,000 pages of legislation
for you to read
in 2006 there were 7,000 there's more
now the bills are bigger now
okay 7,000 pages for someone to read a
year if I gave you 7,000 pages of a
juicy romance you might have a hard time
reading that every year okay it's a lot
of work all right so we're gonna move on
this is particularly the Patient
Protection Affordable Care Act you've
probably heard of under another name 906
pages clean energy and Security Act 1197
lobbying every time I was reading about
lobbying every piece number of political
action committees law in 1970 more than
4,000 since the 1970s have been exposed
to close and lob growth lobbying in the
early 70s no one had a lobbyist now
rythms got a lobbyist lobbying lobbying
lobbying lobbying 70 70 70s declining
confidence surprising to think that
Nixon and his government had a 40
percent and now we're at a 14 percent
decline in confidence for democracy and
capitalism lots of books with very
bizarre titles right capitalism won't
work democracy won't work a lot of that
happening since the 70s this is just one
of those books so yeah something might
have happened there this is a summary of
this I've been back and forth to prayed
about some of this data but max who's
here has actually helped me analyze it
just in the last couple weeks I'm more
optimistic about how confident this this
graph is this graph is terrifying if you
haven't heard of Dylan's work you need
to look up Guillen's work basically what
he's saying is this is the response to
the rich people of legislation and this
is the response to average citizens
whereas often the response to poor
people is negative okay so the response
to average and citizens you'll notice is
a flat line so if 90% of the American
people are against a bill the odds of
that bill passing is 30% if 90% of the
American people are for a bill the odds
of that bill are passing is 90%
that's indifference okay you can get
worse than indifference but indifference
is pretty ugly the response the elites
is more like a referendum right
referendum would be a straight line
coming straight up at a 45-degree angle
it's not a referendum but it's pretty
powerful stuff okay so this is a big
this came out this year this is what
really got me excited about finally
bringing some of my ideas to life okay
so we get all the causes people are
greedy bankers bad governments corrupt
money's evil but it's there a common
cause people are blaming everybody but
it's there one sort of thing well I've
done a lot of work in science whenever I
see growth that looks like the Chinese
privet I think that the Chinese privet
was probably introduced right so the
Chinese privet comes over to wherever it
was in the south and all of a sudden
takes off like a rocket ship
okay this is similar perhaps to what's
going on here I kept seeing the same
strange thing happen at a very specific
time so I'm thinking something got
introduced and people have had their
ideas about what got introduced but they
never seem to explain things very
completely okay so could they all be
related and let me give you the idea of
the scope I'm dealing with here I'm
talking about every major problem that
we're talking about I'm not talking
about the 70s was a utopia and today is
a nightmare I'm just talking about the
dramatic changes from the 70s to now the
EPA right we were passing environmental
bills they're getting disintegrated
banking bills all of that's changing
citizens united can this affect citizens
united the scope that we're talking
about is every major problem and every
major change since the seventies not
small stuff we're going here go for here
but we're particularly looking at
inequality I got in for climate change
when I first started seeing these trends
I was living in Africa I love Africa I
love my wife who's African love my son
is more than Kenya the elections in
particular fascinated me and I was
getting involved with those and I
noticed that they were it was strange to
think about how big a burden running a
free and fair election was you had to
put a ballot booths everywhere people
like oh we don't even think about that's
actually expensive okay so you're going
to deliver all these ballot booths
you're gonna deliver fair accounts
you're gonna police these ballot booths
and do all that there's very expensive
for Africa and often they would plead to
the Western world for support to do
their elections okay which really shot
me but then turns out it's not a typical
right Britain talks about it elections
are expensive can't we do it cheaper
well of course we can right we just toss
it on the phone just like Washington and
Colorado all these places just sticking
it on the phone perfect right well
that's what I was trying to do
and that's when I got schooled by a guy
standing over a grill in Africa and I
told him what I was trying to do isn't
the cryptography for it the cryptography
to david chalmers voting schemes they
all seem to work pretty good
okay the cryptography is great the
unfortunate part Minh this is the
politics and the government of it isn't
great and that's what I had to learn
because I didn't know it at all sadly
and I came to face with something that
almost all of us hold dear what Jeremy
Bentham holds dears were a dream
vermeulen holds dear the people who
talked the beginning this idea of
transparency okay I've done videos on
transparency how can we get more
transparency in the government big deal
for me get great response in those
videos and I wasn't alone as I say right
these guys are for transparency
international sunshine foundation all
these organizations so the million
dollar question if I'm going to replace
voting booths with cell phones why do we
need voting rooms why do we put them up
in the first place all right and people
are probably already jumping to some
ideas it's really important to
understand how powerful this was and how
important this decision was okay so some
people might think of one idea there's
two really huge problems and I debate
myself which one's worse but I think
they're about equal but I think actually
I'll give you a hint
later about which one I think is worse
and it's not the one that most people
think it is the first problem is
intimidation the elections about oh I
don't know beating in the household well
you're gonna have the guy and the wife
in the house looking over their
cellphone and talking about beating in
the household what's gonna happen is she
has likely to vote her conscience if her
husband sitting right there and is ready
to beat her well of course we know that
that's probably not going to happen
intimidation is any method of
frightening or overall in order to make
someone do what someone wants okay this
problem was so big that back in
Philadelphia in 1881 because as very few
people know before 1890 no one voted
with secret ballots in the United States
you've walked into some court rooms and
you vote out loud viva voce right
sometimes you'd use about there are
different ways to vote but every way
that you voted before
90 people could determine how you voted
so what happened well people were
getting killed all right I was gonna
read this whole thing we're running out
of time but there was massive violence
surrounding the dates of elections so
much so that people were saying the
reason why women shouldn't vote is
because it's too dangerous okay that's
not my opinion I think some women are
tougher than guys but that that is what
our people are talking about this is
really bloody and really violent
you couldn't vote for Abe Lincoln down
in the south every moon was too afraid
to even print ballots and carry the
ballots around down in the south
okay that's intimidation free printing
of ballot okay if you voted for someone
if you say you voted for abling walked
into George and said I want to vote for
a boy could they be like excuse me we
vote for the gun I'd be out or something
would happen or more likely what would
happen is your house had burned that
night all right massive massive violence
surrounding elections 1872 in England
they did the ballot before Mac this is
how people voted back then you go up in
front of the courthouse everyone's
standing around I'm gonna go for this
everyone's like oh it's crazy right and
then someone would die someone get beat
up this is a publicity for Lincoln by
Thomas Nash and it just looks like kind
of a regular thing here's how you vote
for Lincoln and here's how you vote for
his competitor but notice the
intimidation already look at this
character does he look sort of clean and
handsome and wonderful no so if you're
gonna walk up you better be looking
clean and handsome because only
respectful people are gonna vote for
Lincoln right and then look at all the
people looking around look at the
swarthy folks ready to handle you if you
vote the wrong way okay the whole idea
of election parades disappeared why
would you have an election parade right
you have an election parades to
incentivize people to watch people to
intimidate people to vote they're gone
okay so secret vote the Voting Rights
Act huh Selma was a big deal no person
show intimidate threaten or coerce any
person for voting or attempting about
intimidations a big deal problem to vote
by everyone knows about that when we all
talk about bribery all the time
Tammany Hall took advantage of pre 1890
ability to see how people vote so what
he do is he'd hand people a chicken wing
outside the election office if they
voted the right way to have his
in there going yeah he voted him a beer
a swig of beer for a vote turnout was
great right a lot of people who didn't
care at all would just show up some
people are all where's the turnout well
vulpine helps turnout so if you want if
you see your turnout rising assume that
there's probably some vote-buying going
George Washington through these
elaborate parties he claimed in 1855
when he lost he didn't buy enough booze
right then he buy booze and walk people
all down to the ballot and then he just
saw you stand around watch them all
drunk and know who's voted right that's
intimidation folks that's vote by
Tammany Hall delivered probably on both
side by George Washington run a race by
buying bobo da all right man charged in
texas with buying school board votes
with cocaine give you a line you vote
for me it's amazing how easy it is to
buy all right and think about the
situation say we're gonna vote and work
this is your boss he's standing over you
he can be like vote for me I'll give you
that promotion right then he can see
that you vote so this can happen in
Washington already right you can do this
now 1890 is no longer you can do it
again okay and he can sit there and go
yeah I'll decide but he's gonna see my
vote right there he'll be able to buy
any time you have the ability to see
someone purchase or intimidate you have
vote buying an intimidation recently
someone from Washington put his vote up
on eBay all right
eBay didn't like that they took it down
made some news pretty exciting stuff
going on all right
the problem with receipts would have
been great during the Florida election
if everyone had a receipt collect all
the receipts this is exactly how we
voted of course receipts allow for both
intimidation vote buying honey when she
gets home from the booth show me how you
voted on that abuse bill show me the
receipt I need that receipt right and
then the beating can happen right there
in the home or the selling and buying
happens right at Tammany Hall doesn't
need someone inside the election room
you can just give me a receipt and I'll
give you a swig of beer okay and this is
indeed what was happening so you don't
get receipts you will never get a
receipt if someone hands you a receipt
about how you voted who you voted for
you're in a different world right they
don't do that so think about it yourself
you want to bribe someone how much would
you pay for a vote you can't verify I
kind of know what your answer will be if
you really do think about this right if
I go to try and give someone money and
I'm pushing them or I'm intimidating
them but they can't see I can't say they
vote they're more likely to vote against
me they're like that guy's a crook right
oh yeah I'm gonna do exactly what you
say then I vote against them so it
actually limits even the approach of
buying okay and this is from Professor I
forget where he's somewhere in the US no
man has ever placed his money corruptly
without satisfying himself that the vote
was cast according to the agreement or
in a phrase which became only too common
during last campaign without proof that
the goods were to be delivered okay so
which one's worse I actually think it's
intimidation just because we've been
doing it forever
okay people talk all about bribery but I
think intimidation Vince I don't update
on that so we teach secret ballots in
the first grade my kids learning it
already three high schoolers do projects
on it Wikipedia nails it right
here's intimidation here's vote by
here's the prevention secret ballot in
which only the voter knows how
individuals have voted a crucial part of
ensuring free and fair elections before
this it was common for candidates to
intimidate or bribe orders I wouldn't
say comment I would say it happened all
the time
right I would like to see a case where
it didn't happen Aristotle is very
concerned about Pliny the Younger was
very concerned about it
they talked openly about this then they
nailed it right and so Aristotle was
trying to develop a voting system
whereby you could vote in public but no
one would be able to tell your vote he
came up with great systems black and
white balls and urns where you put your
hands and drop the balls he had this
other system they were great okay
Congress insists on it Congress passes
legislation to try and make sure you
have secret ballots so since the 1890s
we've upgraded everywhere we vote we
vote in private I don't care if you're
at the PTA a bake sale wherever you vote
you go in private except for one place
US Congress
there's someone in this room who
actually said to me it's like my god
how could we be so blind right is it
possible that the same problems that
apply to a legislator applause that
applied to an individual applied to a
legislator well you tell me what you
think okay so here's gov track us you
can see how every voter ever every
congressman ever voted on almost
anything right so this is a current bill
I don't know to 26 and 191 you can look
up your congressman I can't read it off
the screen and you could see if they
vote again a well oh this is great and
you can actually see that do we have a
maybe I'll click on this can I click on
that oh yeah all right and just for fun
it's really good to familiarize
yourselves with the idea of roll call I
don't know if we have volume all right
well we'll try if not I can maladye I
know it by heart
mr. page all right we'll try let's hope
what there I can actually tell you
mostly what's happening in this thing
anyways so this is a roll call vote
I don't know if we get any more volume
let's see if I could
all right so he's like quiet police
we're gonna have the roll call this how
they did it in Congress they're actually
wrong the Connecticut guys actually were
for the bill but who cares oh well some
people are getting upset already right
they're looking over at each other
you're gonna vote in Congress your votes
going to be sent by telegraph back to
your hometown it's likely that even in
your hometown your house is gonna get
burned that night so think about the
amount of guts it took to make some of
these votes or non guts
sending it by telegraph
back to where your wife and your kids
live right back to where your friends
are who might be very much opposed to
you okay and there's there's a great
scene sir at the end of this but I'm
gonna well this is actually it
[Music]
you shoot me dead I don't care this is
what happened okay so we'll move on so
they voted openly in 1799 they voted
openly that was 1865 January 31st so how
could this be the root of all these
problems if they always voted openly
well they didn't always open both they
didn't always vote openly okay this is a
build and when I was starting to talk
about I thought was the smallest bill in
the world that no one is that part of it
indeed no one really had ever heard of
it
but it wasn't a small bill ten years in
the making the legislative
reorganization Act let's understand what
legislative means those are the people
who make your laws who decide how your
money is spent is going to be
reorganized there are only two of these
acts in history 1946 in 1917 1946 when
didn't have a lot of balls so they
wanted to put some balls into this one
and they did all right so everything
that we think about modern Congress is
done in this bill you've never heard of
it all right
so when you see a television or a camera
inside Congress this is the bill that
did it if you've heard of radio when you
get open voting in 90% of the bills that
are being done this is what did it by
far the most significant anti-secrecy
provision in the Act dealt with the
disclosure of House members votes House
members then changed the Senate changed
the house in the committee of the whole
the house often makes its most important
policy decisions it often makes its most
important policy decisions in secret
okay but for a hundred and eighty years
its precedents had been forbidden to
record to understand how people voted
for 100 1789 to 1970 you couldn't record
them okay so under the new rule each
member's name and vote was to be record
put on government org okay legislative
reorganization Act most people have
never heard of the committee the whole
if you look it up on Wikipedia don't
learn anything it's the worst definition
in the world the committee of the whole
was developed in England to prevent the
very thing we really think it should
prevent from it prevented the ability of
the King to intimidate someone voting so
the legislators the members of
parliament whatever they were called
would go inside the committee the hall
to avoid repercussions with
finance stuff or anything to do with the
king and then they would come out they
would announce their decision but then
their decision would just be a number
the vote total okay and so they were
avoiding the power of money they were
avoiding the super power in the country
in the commune of the whole that's from
England you can probably read up on that
I'll post my slides but here's Wikipedia
it gives you this really dry thing
you'll never understand it so I call
this one of the most important bills in
history other people say that as well
this landmark legislation launched the
congressional reforms to the 70s
transforming the Indus institutions more
than any event or serious events since
the overthrow of speaker Canon speaker
Canon died in 1913 here's the 24 words
right this is straight from the bill the
result of each roll call vote in any
meeting or any committee shall be made
available by that committee for
inspection by the public those are
powerful words they've changed history
okay here's the people who sponsored a
Tip O'Neill who will talk about later
because he became very famous for
abusing the ability to see people's
votes he built Tufts University by a
process called log rolling he didn't
have a penny in his pocket but he built
Tufts University by leaning over junior
senators and junior congressmen and
making sure that they voted the right
way okay and he was a long rollin like
crazy Charles goopster was kind of a sad
sap he was having troubles for
transparency in Congress so he was the
Republican nominee for this lick up
Charles Group so there's not a whole lot
of wonderful things about him he wasn't
a bad guy but it just was kind of there
they proposed this without any data
without any studies okay that there's no
data they were just appealing to popular
sentiment or whatever right and I had
some of O'Neill's words here but the
secrecy of the committee of the whole is
allowed too many members to dis to avoid
the perils of controversial voters and
he went on and on and on and on all
right
committees in general but the committee
the whole was where most of this secret
stuff was happening right so the almost
every major bill landed in the committee
of the whole at some point so they were
doing in just even an example the
committee of the whole might do 50 votes
of the votes for that year inside the
committee whole for one bill okay so
they were all the little amendments all
a little wording would happen then they
go boom this is it
it's done ready okay so community the
whole was a powerful thing I'm not the
committee expert of the world you might
know more than me about that but the
other committees had similar issues okay
the committee the whole though
historically was always private where
the others weren't always right some of
them actually volunteered to be open so
I when I discovered this I tried looking
this up I didn't find any information
anywhere Krugman doesn't mention the
word secret ballot and any one of his
billion blog posts right
Stiglitz doesn't record talked about any
of this is zero this is no one talks
about this issue right it's just
mind-blowing to me right and to
celebrate they added the electronic
voting machine 1973 when I think we see
a lot more dramatic changes because
people were still lazy at the beginning
as you saw taking the roll count was
very slow people would spit in their
platoons they deliberate they added the
electronic one really sped things up and
in 1973 I think you see a lot more
changing so just give you an example of
how this happens and it's insidious how
this happens remember that I'm a fan of
Barney Frank I love the guy but what
he's doing here is he's intimidating by
calling for a roll call vote to make
sure that people he squeezed against the
wall are now gonna put their name to a
bill okay and you're gonna see this this
is recent
you know he's retired but it's recent
enough okay and he's going to do it
after the bills already been approved
okay oh sorry
ha
all right no camera on them that's
secret it's over the bill one speaker
speaker wait yeas and nays is roll call
voting where you attach names to the
votes so now they'll have 15 minutes to
vote we won't watch that but they'll get
up and put their cards in every name
will be published on the board this you
can see on almost every bill and at the
end of almost every A's and nays you'll
see someone go please come up we'll call
we'll call we need roll call why cuz I
want to get the money for this or I want
to push someone around okay a father
findings founding fathers are great but
they didn't talk about this nothing in
the Constitution requires public
sessions of Congress let alone public
hearings of its committees are public
votes affect the Constitution makes no
mention of committees at all okay though
one of the first things they did in the
very first Congress is they develop the
committee of the whole because they love
this thing
okay acceptable in 1789 but not now how
can no one even mention the possibility
of election fraud how could no one argue
for a cardboard box I call it a
cardboard box because you put that thing
up it's the cheapest way to vote
privately you just stick your head in
there and you vote on premade kits for
$5.00 get them while they last
not one congressman to mention mention
election fraud through I read through
the whole 200 pages of the crap the bill
passed 326 to 19 so no one really
thought this was bad of course it's hard
to ask congressman to act for them to be
bald about going I need to be secret so
we can see some issues with trying to
get them to embrace this again because
right if you're gonna be the only
congressman going I think my vote should
be secret everyone's gonna think you're
a criminal
alright and that's partly what we had to
deal with jeremy bentham and that's what
we're gonna have to do a fair meal and
we're gonna have to deal with with
ourselves who are fans of transparency
okay if this is correct no one's talked
about it since I asked Barney Frank
about the legislative reorganization Act
1917 ever heard of it he's retired he
was around in what 80 I asked Chris Dodd
as John barrel asked build dollars right
they never heard of it
they didn't know that voting was changed
in 1970 they didn't know that
okay hundreds of roll-call studies
services every major universities got
them they're just analyzing roll calls
left right and center none of them have
gone shall we compare roll call with
secret not one study it doesn't exist
okay you find one I'd love to read it
so these people are getting lots of
funding to analyze the minutiae of
everything but they aren't talking about
the forest which is whether we should be
doing this or not here's the missing
graph right here's what I think is the
additional graph should be added to the
70s I actually found this in a textbook
they didn't mention anything bad about
this or unusual about it or that
something crazy happened roll-call
voting before 1970 was always under four
hundred two thousand eight got up to
1800 no calls a year names are put on
today I actually think that if you had
corruption before then it actually runs
down here in the 200s right because if
you put someone's name on it there's
room for corruption and people wanted
some of those things open I think there
should be nothing okay that's what I
think there was this huge excitement
over transparency so before it passed
and then after this huge excitement my
favorite article which is my last slide
but it'll be up there actually talked
about why this dropped and it had a lot
to do with watchdog groups finally going
well the legislation that gets passed in
secret is better the watchdog groups
themselves were giving up like please
yeah just do it in secret but out in
public I'll be like go transparency
that's the Adrian Bernoulli that's the
Bentham problem we're so much a fan of
transparency that even when we go to
question this we still sight on
transparency despite all the data okay
Baba Kennedy talked about it I'm gonna
run through some data so we cuz I'd
rather have some questions and stuff it
isn't theoretical we've got lots of data
ba-ba-ba-ba we've already seen that we
have motivation clearly lots of money we
have the ROI return on investment lobby
groups brag about it if you give me a
dollar I'll get you back 100 right the
return on investment is phenomenal it's
a big deal especially if a congressman
makes $174,000 a year and they can't
even afford
on a podunk election in their own town
we have motivation the massive hours
this is a big deal how much time do you
spend raising money talking money
pandering to these folks okay well
that's a big deal they spend a lot of
hours so where did that time used to go
well used to go to the people it had to
because those are the people who put you
in office so people are like why isn't
anybody voting right why isn't anybody
interested why doesn't anyone care well
because we're the congressmen who used
to run down here it's true I was a kid I
remember congressmen coming to my town I
haven't seen that I can't even email my
congressmen they don't respond to me
right why would they respond to me your
statistical analysis here's bartels he
talked about how low income groups like
everyone talks about have a negative
response from the government
okay bartels is not a questionable
character he's been doing this forever
middle income medium response high
income great response thanks bartels
we've got people's the little younger
guys written some of the more
provocative stuff on this he was over at
Harvard the Safra Center and he came to
the same conclusion I'm not going to try
and read stuff I can't see with my eyes
but this is a big deal all right
this particular one's big Wayne does the
corruption happen it doesn't happen on
the big bills if you are aware of the
bill there's no corruption right but
remember there are thousands of votes
every year so they're going to
congressmen are dumb they know which
ones you're looking at if you're looking
at it they're gonna vote the way they
believe or the way you believe and
they're gonna say to be damned with the
money right because those are the five
votes a year out of 5,000 that you care
about so the people care about a
statistically insignificant number of
bills and we see that all right so all
the data is pointing to that during
election year they're more likely to be
less corrupt and if it's a public bill
they don't move all right this is great
this is from our friend formulade 2006 I
won't go into this but basically he was
shocked he just keeps being shocked
transparency seems to wreck everything
but at the end he votes for secrecy you
know but every data that he brings up
even the dismissal support the case
there's the Brookings Institute right
Brookings Institute talks about pre and
transparency and whatever years they put
their 1984 is pre true
that's everything was secret before that
1984 was the beginning of transparency
they are unaware the Brookings Institute
does not know about the 1970 legislative
reorganization Act which brought the
televisions in that they talked about
which opens up voting here's two of the
big thinkers in the space barber
McCarthy's of Princeton here's Barbara
they stumble on this idea they think
maybe these committee votes are really
the problem and they poopoo it they go
it's unlikely that a one time real
change would change things for this long
change things for the last 30 years well
if you change your voting that would
change things forever okay and they
prepare it in a number of ways they say
that on the state level we don't see the
same [ __ ] well we see the same pattern
the states changed at the same time so
Florida was the first to go but all
around the same years they're changing
everything that they pull within this
little thing as you probably can already
tell a suspect
okay so Brookings Institute barber these
are the guys who are holding the rock
down for the transparency institutions
and if you'll notice the people writing
for the Brookings Institute work for
transparency institutions so that's
troublesome lobbyists admissions I've
been in touch a lot with David King over
this he's been sending me some juicy
tidbits so he spoke with John Sora's
this legislator Zorich said I was there
the legislature the lobbyists loved this
legislation they loved it and that
capitalization by the way isn't mine
okay if you need just two votes you and
and you knew it you knew who because you
would see during the 50 votes who to
target so you could put your money in a
very specific spot so if you only had a
million dollars to spend you could do a
lot of damage with a million dollars if
you don't know who's voting against you
you now spread a million dollars out by
400 congressmen or whatever else you got
to do and you're not gonna move anything
you're not gonna move one vote you're
gonna be spending a lot of money and
people are already voting for you or
people who are going to be voting
against you and if you can't see the
vote they're gonna vote against many
ways all right endless congressmen
admissions I'm going to keep moving the
turning points that we talked about
congressmen complaining about it here's
packwood 69 he starts
in 1974 he says before this legislation
and this is a big deal the lobbyists
used to walk in and they used to beg
okay
before they used to beg after this
legislation they would tell you what to
do they didn't even need to listen to
you
okay and so he says it really eloquently
but once lobbyists knew your every vote
they used it as ammunition and they
would come after you with congressmen
fighting it this is from my favorite
article every piece in this article
supports my idea but that's from 1987
Rostenkowski would close down the house
and ways means commissions and he would
pass all the legislation that the
watchdogs liked because it was closed
and he why did he close it he would say
because of the lobbyists and when he
closed it he got things done so here's
before 1970 I fought like a tiger knew
that's an actual quote you would just
lie to them I felt like a tiger in there
but we lost man we really worked hard
all right after they were just but just
let me try out please who cares who
cares what the congressman says at that
point it's over okay
back to renewal and Benton how am i
doing for time I don't I want some
discussion so if I'm running late okay
five minutes so these guys are great so
if you're merely struggling with with
Bentham and his transparency struggling
with his things called doing open and
secret voting which he actually
advocates at the end Bentham is
basically saying let's do open it secret
but let secret win so if there's a tie
secret will always win and this is
troubling vermeuhlen because before and
all his papers Bentham says open voting
is the only way to go because everybody
loves transparency right so Bentham
comes to this outrageous weird
conclusion we're really struggling with
it but this is from Bentham's paper
about something happened in Russia on
the second occasion the open vote gave
for the independence of the Commission
114 against to 148 but the secret vote
turned the majority on the other side
for independence 140 against 122 these
are things that are happening one day
after another so people are feeling
liberated perhaps or greedy we don't
know what but there's a change and the
change is big all right the fact that no
one's researching this is weird but
with the birth of an industry when I saw
this I almost fell over all the lobby
groups that you know about are born in
the next few years of this legislation
and they're born to punks
all right Cassidy was driving around in
this little band he was poor him and his
wife didn't have a job he's like maybe
I'll go to Washington be a lobbyist so
he sets up shop behind his stove in his
kitchen in Washington DC has no office
right but he's now doing lobbying when
lobbying works before that every single
lobbyist wore a cheap suit within a
month he's getting a $10,000 check and
then he starts getting more and more and
more and more they didn't understand it
how would he know he didn't know life
beforehand Alec Foundation all of these
guys in 1972 1975 you see the dates over
and over and over and then they own the
market right so K Street was built by
this bill so the weird thing about this
is it's kind of like discovering gravity
or oxygen or air once you see it you see
it everywhere this is from the newspaper
Boehner is standing over his members and
going I'm watching how you're voting if
you don't vote the right way I'm not
gonna listen to your bill that's
intimidation no one calls it intimidate
we call whipping up the bone why do I
give it such a euphemism
that's intimidation that's actually
electoral fraud intimidation okay no one
ever calls it that this is an amazing
stuff right here the intimidation and
pressure was intense this from the
Congress right this is Boehner right
here there are a lot of people that
wanted to vote no today and last call
the last twisting of arms did they
literally twist their arms the last
twisting arms convinced them not to vote
that way all right it goes on and on if
you're young you get beat up even more
one freshman lawmaker was called prior
to the voice and told their committee
seat was probably gone if you would vote
your conscience oh my god they even use
the word conscience right we didn't even
think they knew that word they know it
they don't want you to have it all right
threatening other party members hey
we're not gonna threaten Elizabeth
Warren she's too awesome right but we're
too threatened every single other
Democrat if you do anything with
Elizabeth Warren well its intimidation
and they can follow that up and they do
okay your gang style intimidation well
that makes a lot of sense you can't form
a gang unless you see how the other
members of your gang or voted right you
can't form a phalanx unless you turn
around they go oh well he voted we all
voted the same way we all vote for each
other's bills and we all hate Obama
we're gonna crush the Obama it would all
move together you can't do that unless
you see how they vote Wow there you go
that's not the only way I think there's
a lot of reasons this is great
remember what he's talking about aid to
Hurricane sandy seventy votes if you
voted for aid for hurricane sandy you
were in trouble
alright and they would see your vote and
they would go after you imagine if they
couldn't see your vote well you might be
able to use that conscience thing you
have vote buying yes we've got it
no one really calls it what it is that's
election fraud right that's bribery we
call it other things quid pro quo let's
just call what it is this is secret
ballot curable stuff okay
massive vote buying I don't know how
many vertebra Cunningham do Cunningham
put out a menu if you want this type of
legislation that's this much if you want
this type of legislation that's this
much when he got caught he did time in
jail he wasn't the only one guys were
hiding money in their freezers all of
this stuff alright people talk about
trying to stop money going into their
hands that's impossible
alright if I invest in a snake farm in
Guam does that help a congressman you'll
never figure that out
okay but what if we can stop the
feedback loop where they get to know if
that money worked then we see the money
go down Tammany Hall wasn't giving
anyone a chicken wing or a swig of beer
after 1890 they were giving nobody
nothing there were no election parades
George Washington wouldn't buy booze
after that
all right the secret ballot stops the
money is a crucial feedback loop that's
interrupted all right all right so I've
got more but I'm gonna end there because
I think you get it though this is my
this is my graphs these are important
here's an equality which actually the
guys at Princeton said correlates almost
dramatically with partisanship and
correlates with a lot of other stuff so
inequality correlates very well with
partisanship and it also no one's ever
done this correlates really well with
house roll call votes which would be the
opposite right it should be the opposite
stuff this is outrageous I think we can
explain even the peaks and valleys with
data that we have but the correlation
that it has with inequality is
terrifying okay
the secret ballot worked in the previous
Gilded Age not a lot of date on it but
all the results that I'm seeing are
saying that is one of the main reasons
why we ended the first Gilded Age and
this is one of the Articles that
corroborate with that so I could go on
forever I'd like to open up for
questions I'm sure you have some
[Applause]
could always do that the trouble is
people what you were getting what you
were getting was unreliability you'd get
congressman telling two different groups
they vote at different ways all right
you've got what packwood said which is
he would tell the other congressmen to
tell the lobby group that he voted one
way all right and that was covered in
the thing that I sped through but
packwood would say we fought like a
tiger in there for you we did everything
we could I did all I could
how much are you gonna pay for that if
you are smart enough to know that he
could be lying right so the money goes
down regardless it's unreliable
information there was this whole thing
called spotters which hard to find stuff
on but people were planting people in
Congress to try and figure out how they
were voting beforehand that was
unreliable so the money was low I'm a
terrible actor but I can do this one
really well all right you're the
lobbyist who come into my office I told
every [ __ ] out there that I
voted no but Perry I voted yes
okay but all I'm saying is that same
thing you underestimate the ability for
the press to work in the 70s the
reporters were very aggressive they were
trying to put people on the spot
there were spotters there trying to put
their names you would see lists of how
people wrote it trouble is even goopster
who proposed this bill was disagreeing
with those lists so he was publicly
disagreeing with lists of what either he
had said before or whatever it's just
unreliable right it's you are going down
to someone's worth he could lie just
because he doesn't like you you know
that he knows that all right and I'm
just saying the ability to lie the
ability to be secret is what changes the
game no question we're in a different
world 2015 is different
I think lying and those games still play
fairly well
in isolation
it's not thing you haven't identified a
problem
I don't think there's any way I could I
I agree with you I think you're
absolutely right I do think that when we
take in a leap of faith we took a leap
of faith in 1970 and if we look at the
legislation pre-1970 granted things have
changed but man is that like we're
talking the lowest point of inequality
the lowest point of partisanship in
history this bill changed more than one
thing it allowed for more open
committees so you can sit as once
Reporter said in 1972 on the
congressman's elbow the lobbyists would
sit there right during the write-up of
the bills all of that I mean it's it's
it's a maddening amount of transparency
the one link though is if you're
investing a lot of money and you can't
see the boat well you've now lost that
that the vote is the tie to whether what
you invested in worked or not right so
if you invest in the think tanks if you
invest in whatever the think tanks are
on the take is the reporter from New
York Times recently said all that but
they're putting money in specifically
for results that they can see if you
can't see the results then you put in
less I'm not saying it's going to take
it to zero I'm saying it's a change
go ahead I have a new platform the way
it's gonna work is we're gonna left
people and we are gonna have votes
online and what policy stances they
should take every booth bill they're
going to vote on we're gonna have full
information on it and if they don't do
what we say you know we're gonna throw
mom we're gonna stop using money so on
and so forth and when you look at this
it first looks like an interesting idea
this looks like how you actually
realize that very much this is design
its deliberative so design is a system
where you have a representative who can
engage in exactly the sort of
horse-trading backroom dealing
conversation that we have and so I'm
very sympathetic to this argument as
being consistent with what we want a
deliberative representative democracy to
be actually want the possibility that
our representatives deliberate and that
god forbid they change their minds and
that they're actually able to do it in
Kampala so that all sounds right to you
but in this 45-minute talk I didn't hear
voters mentioned after minute 10 it
became a conversation about lobbyists
and what I'm really curious about is if
we were turned to this culture of
secrecy how do you get to the problem of
that student was trying to solve that
student was really interested in the
question of I don't believe in this
legislators I don't believe that they're
representing me I don't believe that
they're acting on my behalf if we have
the restoration of super state they're
talking about it's very very difficult
to have voters feel like they have any
sense for what's going on how do you
campaign how do you represent your work
how do you actually have a
representative election in a situation
where you remove that ability to I love
that question I that's something I think
of a lot about and I think it actually
is the change of motivations that I
presented through data but I'll make
clear say I'm writing a bill now and I
really am worried about lobbyists POV or
I'm worried about someone else's POV but
I don't want the public to understand
I'm gonna write a longer bill and I'm
gonna write a really complex bill if you
look at her Bill of Rights it's one page
ten bills that changed dramatically that
change of your ability to read and
follow legislation is gone all right
remember that what everything became
inwardly facing since the 70s so instead
of reaching back to the people which is
gone and engaging the people and showing
the people their bit your bill and
trying to get them to understand your
legislation they turned and did the
exact opposite so you get lobbyists who
are from Harvard
MIT etc - right wording and they talk
about this right the people who get
caught talk about how crafty they wrote
that wording right
Abramoff talked about hiring some of the
best and brightest to write one clause
to screw everybody over if you're
writing the bill where the only
acceptance you're looking for is the
public well then you have to go and meet
the public you have to go and write for
the public so you're talking a whole
different way of writing bills you're
talking a whole different face on your
Congressman right so you've changed the
interaction with the voter for the
entire time not just his election but
every time you writes a bill now you
have to read it right would it be great
if he wrote as I forget who wrote it but
sorry I wrote a long bill I didn't have
tried to write a short way they'd be
working to write the shorter once again
I'll get you one two then three
there is you know I don't I did go
through the communities I did look at
the things they were passing so at that
point they were passing all the major
stuff when they were talking about so
Tip O'Neill talks about war based
initiatives finance based initiatives
right the SST supersonic which was a big
deal then and which many people claim
that the open voting change the the
legislation on that we can go back and
and look at but I have my guess is it's
going to touch and it have touched
almost every bill beforehand because you
would write your amendments in the
committee of the whole you could switch
to committee a whole return very quickly
as you might know the hardest thing to
get data on is secret ballots right so
you're not going to find how someone
voted you're not going to see you're
gonna have to pull for partisanship
numbers the partisanship numbers all end
in 1970 for very good reason right and
then we have this sort of guessing based
on
I they could have done that 1970 they
could have done in 1969 they didn't I I
I agree and I I think it would be less
likely for them to lie as they would
write in a small office was with one
person but once again we're talking five
thousand votes a year probably half of
them the only conversations they're
having on that are with particular
lobbyists okay and those are the people
that they're going to be upset with or
the people they're gonna have some sort
of personal and they're gonna be getting
pushed around by these people I would
say the propensity to lie might actually
be fairly high on the particular bills
where we're seeing the most corruption
right I don't think they're gonna move
on big ideas I think they're gonna be
very public about it and I think they're
gonna pretty much follow their heart
it's so hard to say the if we go back to
Adrian and Jeremy right they both sided
on secrecy even though every k-state
show show where I mean they cited on
transparency where every case they show
mentioned that secrecy changed things
dramatically and might have meant more
on it than as Bentham kept saying I
think it's the honest vote and the
partisanship factor here is really the
key right you get a lot of soft money
based on how you vote you get a lot of
internal right I did a whole thing and
why partisanship happens and people link
partisan stick with inequality and I
think for good reason
and it's because you get bullied on how
you vote on everything this talk to
congressmen walking in and seeing how
the top five people voted and voting
appropriately I think we're gonna see
examples like Adrienne and Jeremy found
where people are saying one thing and
doing the other I think that'll come out
quickly
and as soon as you see that then we know
we're dealing this between the data
right I think I've been doing
I don't know it's just incredible what
happens in super you don't know why
but it's gonna flip by the fact that
there's a whole industry now kind of
grown up that is more powerful and
paying more attention a lot to using
transparency so my question then would
be transparencies away what are what are
the other metrics or ease of
accountability hold in there yeah I mean
I I think it's awesome that I'm old
enough to remember when we thought
congressmen were pretty awesome and well
I'm I'm 50
so I remember some of this and you can
go back and you can start talking about
how we judge congressmen we didn't judge
them by their votes because we couldn't
write the voting was rare so if you talk
about Kennedy being a senator and he
talks very dramatically about how he
thought open voting shouldn't happen
because you get pushed around by the
people he thought it'd be a tyranny of
the majority the data seems to suggest
that it's a tyranny of the minority of
attorney of the rich and we elected that
they came out and made sure that we knew
everything about it right they had to
impress us whatever metric we judge
anybody a lover a boyfriend candidate
their their past record maybe they
worked in Africa maybe they they built
something you like or involved in
organizations yeah yeah they they they
they now had to impress you with those
other metrics and I don't think we
determine what those metrics are in
advance because those metrics could be a
number of things and I think they'll
change dramatically based on whether
we're in the middle of a Vietnam War a
different war or all this other stuff
that's going on
right now right so the incentive is to
both in ways we get you money to get me
elected because that's what you're
judged on how you hope and I mean on the
big issues for the public what they do
how you go correct right with the super
about you're down on the outcome of the
product of the bill is that you know
somebody that essentially supports the
bill and the outcomes of those bills
that those things are consistent that's
how they can actually that's what
they're aiming for the best possible
outcome so that they win the votes back
way as opposed to
well I'll respond I agree I'm not as
middle-of-the-road about this I do think
that citizens united relies on this bill
right there is no citizens united
without this okay so people are very
concerned just about citizens united the
ability to pour money in based on how
someone votes
well what if we take away the ability to
verify that all right if we talk about
climate change I've worked with many
lobbyists on climate change issues you
go into the office and unfortunately
they're sitting there going I hear you
I really do I mean I understand the
science blah blah blah and then you look
at its funders and he speaks very
publicly about how he's against it and
this is a common response from people
who work on climate change right that
they are in trouble if they voice their
opinions on it and dramatically in
trouble so they have to weigh how big an
issue it is to the public and what they
can do about it so I am NOT as
pessimistic about it as an idea I
actually think it it correlates
dramatically well with all the problems
which is just jaw-dropping
it's pretty hard to sneeze at the
correlation which should go the other
way but it also has it's it's the same
results in history proven proven it's
passed very well so it's not researched
at all so I'm I'm literally pleading for
for this to be a research topic a
question an article there is not a
single article on this if it's possible
that it causes this why aren't we
talking about it at all the leap of
faith as you talked about happen in 1970
difference between direct democracy and
representative democracy in which no
your student wanted to micromanage
wanted every citizen to vote on every
issue which i think is a really bad idea
I think this would force us to morph to
back candidates who we think are wise
and have our best interests at heart
now the evaluations a little trickier
right there isn't a trust there but I
think as opposed to the system we have
now where you know what's gonna happen
to that candidate once you vote for him
it sort of doesn't matter who you vote
for because but the one thing that
bothered me a little bit about your
presentation is it it was always this
assumption without true tonight I know
you're you're anxious to study this that
does one can imagine instances work is
just voting in secret might actually
work against the public know what like
to see is some sort of controlled study
where one action can compare the two I'd
like to offer one I think that the 13th
amendment might have worked if that was
there was a lot of pressure Abraham
Lincoln put a lot of pressure on
individual voters he the movie talks
about it the history talks about it he
was pushing for the last five votes now
those are the last five transparent
votes I think it's possible that if it
was all secret all along it might have
passed earlier but certainly in the last
round given transparency it might have
lost had he not put the pressure
oh sorry
exactly and and the other argument the
word and the less unkind way to say that
is it's simple compelling and to me the
strikes make simple compelling and I
think there's a lot of things that are
going on at the same inflection point
that we're talking about that are
interactive and very very complicated
what's hard about this wisdom argument
is that you've gone in the u.s. from one
representative representing 140,000
people which is in fact the one thing
that Washington is Islam in the
Constitution is almost no commentary on
it except he thinks 1 to 40,000 as well
you've had an enormous explosion in
population you now have roughly 1 to
700,000 so it's much much harder to have
that sort of personal relationship of I
know who you are I trust you you know me
you know my values you've simply moved
to a different region because we no
longer scale the House of
Representatives in the same way second
you have a similar shift that's happened
along the same line of the presence of
millionaires and billionaires within
Congress and the Senate you've gone from
having income of the people who are
representing us being within a multiple
of the average income to being many men
multiples of the average income these
things are happening at the same time as
you have a ship going into the late 70s
in the early 80s of people literally
trying to make the case that government
can do no right and that's essentially a
way of saying don't bother paying
attention to these bozos they're not
actually doing anything for me
I think you have a really critical
insight I think you're absolutely right
that the way in which deliberation is
happening within the House and the
Senate has changed radically I think
it's really important I totally agree
with you that it should be studying this
sort of these different factors
interactive I think it's really hard to
undo and simply move back to a pre 1970
model because I think a lot of these
other complicating factors at the same
time make it really really hard to
recover that sort of 1960s politics
where you do have a representative who
feels much closer to the voter interest
and where you would have that sort of
trust relationship so I absolutely think
you're on the right target I think
you're way over terminate in terms of
making this so the solution to it and I
think that's where you're getting to
push back around this question of why
would I trust any of these guys these
guys at this point are not from my quite
privileged socio-economic strata they
are 10x of where I am and I've been
pretty damn good shape these people have
no personal relationship with me nor
have they for 20 or 30 years through
some of these scaling issues so I love
to see this as part of a complement of a
larger well I'd also think that it's a
lens and I think it's important to even
look at your particular critique as a
lens I think it's interesting to think
of the freedom that you might have if
you were rich enough to afford your own
campaign so all of a sudden you can look
more honest and you can look more
convincing and you could look more
unique all right if you're poor and
you're relying on investors well all of
a sudden you're not going to appeal to
the voter nearly as much so as the money
raises keep in mind that the the money
might be being raised by this particular
bill and and isolating fewer and fewer
intriguing people who just happen to be
rich because they're able to speak their
mind so if we control the way people
think
by controlling the money and
intimidating them then we do end up with
very interesting billionaires and very
boring or people I strangely I look at
sports I'm jaw dropped at where the
Muhammad Ali's have gone as they're
there now pandering for all the money
that they get from Nike right and we've
noticed that even when Charles Barkley
used to be very colorful we don't have
them anymore no one's being colorful
anymore because the money is controlled
how they speak okay so we have the same
issue and I don't think that it's
changed dramatically I think there was a
lot of money in politics and politicians
in particular running back in the day I
mean Woodrow Wilson clearly wasn't for
the Roosevelt smart poor we had a number
of fairly wealthy off people but I think
it's interesting that they're able to
speak their minds better the the the
issue about the amount of
Representatives I I agree I mean III
think that's that's a disaster but if we
multiply that by the fact that they're
not at all looking at the people they're
no longer going back to their towns
they're no longer going back to their
their constituency at all they don't
respond to my emails at all I think it's
a time factor they're out of time and so
you know even though they have more
ability to reach masses they don't have
the time to even use the mass
communication tools that they have to
reach out to the people
[Applause]